this animation is brought to you by the
smart image base a subscription website
where you can download thousands of
medical images and videos to use in
lectures courses presentations
professional training and more for more
information click on the link in the
description
you or someone you care about has been
diagnosed with ovarian cancer this video
will help you understand the disease and
how it may affect you
women have two ovaries they are on
either side of the uterus
the ovaries are part of the reproductive
system that makes and stores eggs
ovaries also make the hormones estrogen
and progesterone
two fallopian tubes are attached to the
uterus
after an egg is released from the ovary
it passes through one of the tubes to
the uterus
the ovaries lie close to the peritoneum
the peritoneum is the inner lining of
the abdomen that also covers most of the
organs in your abdomen and pelvis
most ovarian cancers begin in the outer
layer of the ovary
this is called epithelial ovarian cancer
cancer occurs when cells grow out of
control
abnormal cells continue to divide
and may spread to other parts of the
body
germ cell tumors are another type of
ovarian cancer they start in the cells
that make eggs
stromal tumors are a third type they
begin in the supporting tissue of the
ovaries where hormones are made
a number of factors may raise your risk
of epithelial ovarian cancer
one risk factor is age half of ovarian
cancers happen in women aged 63 or older
obesity is another risk factor
women with a body mass index of 30 or
greater have a higher risk
the risk is also higher for women who
have their first baby after age 35
or who have never had a baby
taking hormone therapy with estrogen
alone after menopause may raise your
risk
and having a family history of ovarian
and certain other cancers can also
increase risk
ovarian cancer may have no early
symptoms symptoms of ovarian cancer are
often vague when symptoms do appear they
may include pain in the pelvis or
abdomen
gas or bloating
irregular menstrual bleeding
feeling that you always need to urinate
constipation
and back pain
however in most cases these symptoms are
caused by conditions that are not
ovarian cancer
if you have ovarian cancer your doctor
will need to determine the subtypes of
ovarian carcinoma the grade and the
stage or progression of the disease to
help plan your treatment
each grade is based on how different the
cancer cells look compared to normal
ovary cells under a microscope
the higher the grade the more aggressive
the cancer is
each stage for ovarian cancer is based
on how far cancer cells have spread from
where they began
stage 1 means the cancer is only within
the ovaries
at stage 2 the cancer has spread to
other organs but is still within the
pelvis
in stage 3 cancer has spread beyond the
pelvis to either the peritoneum or the
lymph nodes behind the peritoneum or
both
stage 4 means the cancer has spread to
organs outside the peritoneum
as you deal with a diagnosis of ovarian
cancer continue to talk to your doctor
and your cancer care team